it is I your ruler your God ruler too
heavy I am the creator of the h3
universe foolish Maximus Lord amiss
there is an influencer I'm an influencer
and I am the host of this podcast the h3
podcast the number one place for news
viral hits and weekly gasps I am your
host Ethan Clyde joined with my
beautiful wife my better half even
though I am a god
wouldn't that make you light whoa
he loved the light thank you to our
sponsors expressvpn and for hims got a
big announcement on Wednesday of next
week we're gonna be doing the podcast on
Wednesday because Andrew yang for
president candidate is joining us on
Wednesday which is super exciting you
yang Yang
my brother was deep into the yang gang
and he's got me on board and I was like
well you know album a tweet him and see
if he wants to come on because my
brother's like he's he's down to do
interviews like he was on Joe yeah he's
out there so I just tweeted at him and
it was a direct tweet and it saw I was
surprised but I got a lot of traction
cuz it was just a direct tweet he's
joking like 10,000 likes mom and they
noticed and so that was like only one
week ago and he's coming on in a way in
less than a week now so things move fast
in the yang gang 2020 but I got to tell
you I like what he says I like him as a
candidate I like him into debates I
think that I may be part of the yang
gang but we're less problem let's
brought him let's see what he's got on
Wednesday you know you can leave
questions for him on the subreddit it's
excited I am excited and I don't like I
was saying last time I hate politics but
I feel like he talks about it in a way
that it's just more about life and not
like right or left or well the
thing that I think everyone is so tired
of including me said you look at
everyone else on that stage they all are
just it's all talking points mm-hmm it's
just there's nothing of substance ever
said nobody ever walks away from and
it's all about who can goof the other
person like Kamala Harris she got like a
huge boost in the last debate because
she slammed dunked on Biden over some
but it's like well I don't care about
what how good your one-liners are let's
have a [ __ ] debate let's judge people
on their merits and their their ideas we
don't get to see that but yang actually
he shined because he didn't have a lot
of time but when he spoke he spoke with
clarity and purpose and and it wasn't
participating in the drama not at all he
totally rose above the drama and when he
spoke it wasn't it wasn't just fluff it
was like he was a very effective
communicator and so I'm I'm on board and
who better to vet a potential future
president than me I thought you guys say
your brother know that me you're on the
h3 podcast we're definitely gonna have
him at the giant babe and I'm gonna ask
him if he's tits or ass and if he has
any ghost stories no I'm kidding they
can be very professional wipe from the
front on the back yeah exactly who
better than makes a big deal who better
than I we don't vote right or left will
vote front or back right if anyone from
Andrew Yang's campaign is watching this
I'm kidding the word I'm afraid they're
gonna cancel the more time they have to
think you know no I'm I'm I'm gonna be
prepared I'm I'm very much looking
forward to it yeah it's gonna be fun
big headlines coming in this week you
guys probably remember that in one of
the last recent episodes I went on a
rant about twitch
yep I said they're not gonna last
they're not gonna make it because
they're short-sighted and they don't
know how to keep their talent because
they're so cheap which is shocking
considering they're owned by the richest
man that has ever walked this earth he's
so rich he wipes his ass with
hundred-dollar bills yeah he's starting
to annoy me
but yeah go on of course how I mean good
what do we calculate that he makes like
six billion dollars a day or something I
don't know anymore it doesn't matter
it's numbers and that no one knows it's
it's obscene yeah it's obscene but then
you keep hearing about how Amazon is not
treating their workers well or how about
that they don't even have enough to
[ __ ] like give to which the funds
they need when dude is only is worth
five hundred billion or something I
don't I don't know what he's worth but
it's ridiculous no man should no man
will ever be that rich without you know
cutting every corner in his path hmm you
know I mean yeah well Twitter ninja one
of the probably the most famous twitch
streamer of all time announced in a very
dramatic fashion that he is leaving
twitch to stream exclusively on a new
website named mixer which is owned by
Microsoft so Microsoft is bankrolling
mixer which is attempting to take a cut
of the deep space yeah and guess what
they're actually putting their money
down to do it I think I think the
opportunity here is not to create a
profitable business but to it's just
whenever you can have people engaging on
congregating like to like twitch is one
of the most trafficked websites in the
United States that's the same with you
YouTube in itself rarely may actually
ever mix money but from a marketing
standpoint mm-hmm with Google with that
in its repertoire is what is priceless
you know for the research for the
analytics for the data you know
expanding Adsense it's all part of their
catalogue
and so I think that Microsoft is doing a
very intelligent play here where Amazon
has just continually failed for one
reason or another due to management or
lack of fun which twitch sorry twitch in
Amazon and Amazon thereby is continuing
to fail and Microsoft sees an
opportunity and and there is an
opportunity there is of course so he
made a really dramatic announcement here
I'll show you guys and you know what's
funny I want to show you guys real quick
you guys remember how I said once I left
to go to to back to YouTube that they
remove my sub button so within minutes
of ninja announcing he was going over to
mixer exclusively they removed his sub
button do you believe how petty and
pathetic you have to do what you do that
they were gonna lose a ton of money it's
up to ninja like if he wants to don't
get this move cuz they have to go out of
the way probably to do that why like
with us we we may still have stream
sometimes who knows why would you do
that exactly why would you burn it's
burning the brain yeah but here's the
annoying thing he's gonna have to go
back cuz I'm sure they owe him money a
lot of money he's gonna have to go back
and sign back up to get paid that's what
they did to me it's on your vindictive
bridge burning that's like high school
level of drama remove his sub button
okay try to be more professional yeah
and you know I've seen people saying I
saw one dumbass on Twitter saying maybe
I can pull it up okay can you guys pull
it up there's this one guy I saw I saw
it because Chris Raygun responded to it
and maybe you can find it there on
through his replies just bitching about
how ninja is a sellout for betraying
twitch I want to watch that cuz I think
over you know I think that guy
represents a lot of people's opinions I
want you to rebut that argument
maybe train yeah as if ninja didn't do
way more for twitch than they did for
him or I mean it was reciprocal mayor's
wife we love you if we leave you too
don't we we train you too no no of
course not it's free market you need
competition
that's like saying bro how could you
leave Comcast after all they've done for
you how dare you
well anyway he's out here let's watch
his announcement video I wonder I'm sure
twitch didn't know about this ahead of
time and he was streaming like everyone
was usual and man they must have [ __ ]
the [ __ ] bed when they saw this I
feel like this is it I feel like they're
done they're probably finally pinching
him to like you only did 5 hours today
and we really want you to push to 7 I'm
sure I'm sure
I've spoke to another one of the top
five streamers on Twitch and I'm not
gonna say his name because it was a
private conversation but he told me
after watching our highlights that they
pinched his ass hard too and he so over
it and he doesn't understand it and he's
now he's thinking about going to mixer
too if he can close the deal with them
it's kind of corny so I'm not gonna
watch a little thing but just give you
guys I know this may come as a shock to
many of you but as of today I will be
streaming exclusively on mixer
I know I know it's exciting the only do
yes the handsome guy in the front how is
this going to affect your gaming
abilities it really won't it's the same
meat just a different platform what are
you most excited for about this change
you know I feel like this is a really
good chance to get back and touch with
my roots so I can either I don't mind
the video oh you didn't know oh excuse
me I thought it was [ __ ] done in the
first place who's wondering what is a
switch mean for the future of your hair
you never know and then here they have a
fridge of Red Bulls posing a question
Wow
I mean that was one of the best
questions I've ever been asked why
didn't you answer it Wow any other
questions right I didn't understand that
oh yeah it wasn't very well they should
have zoomed in on the fridge because
that first I actually didn't know what
what so that the fridge of Red Bulls is
asking them a question is that a meme of
some kind I think there's like Red Bull
okay
am i right does anyone have any intel on
that I'm assuming it's just they love
red that was one of the best questions
I've ever been asked it's probably
sponsor
however the sector win-loss ratio
I really would why would it affect
worrying too much about my win-loss
ratio I'll be just fine yeah it's a
little corny yeah you know yellow likes
it I'll finish it well it's a little
more effort than nothing
you're right it is good upper it shot
well yeah so there you go and I mean it
got ten million views so [ __ ] me I'm as
far as marketing Santa War yeah I've
seen worse and it shot well I will say
that for it did you find that video by
chance back there no I've been looking
I'm on Chris Reagan's replies there are
a few things that he yeah it looks like
maybe it was removed or oh okay well
anyway at the gist well I know what you
mean though there were people saying
sellout how can you betray to which it's
like everything they've done for you the
[ __ ] is twich done for anyone platform
yeah loyalty did on a platform like that
is a bizarre to me but ninja but you
know it's stupid to say that because
ninjas done at least as much for the
platform as as they could have never
done for him probably has done the most
for bringing them to mainstream he's
he's been on magazine covers on Ellen
show if he left the only reason is that
twitch failed to retain him yeah being
cheap yes is cuz they thought they were
the only one in the game but guess what
they're not if anything they betrayed
him because the way I see it is maybe he
had a slight drop for something in views
or subscribers he did will go okay so
they're like okay well your views are
dropping so you're not worth as much to
us yeah which is such a gross way to
look at it because you should look at it
as long-term you may have a drop now and
then pick up again I mean everyone like
on YouTube you see it a lot with big
channels you know you go through phases
right you got a you got a look at your
partners as long
not just someone who's bringing your
views at the moment and then throw them
out right
I'm sure that's what happened just a
capacity I mean it's all been based on
my assumptions but well twitch makes
deals with with their hi hi partners I
must I'm just assuming YouTube does that
to some where they help supplement their
income in some ways or give them better
cuts or deals or whatever mm-hmm and I'm
sure that ninja had some kind of deal
with them but they they prime sure
you're right because they did the same
thing with a penny pitch and just give
you [ __ ] and they like count your hours
that you're streaming and they yet they
probably drove him away he says I don't
know he keeps saying that he's getting
back to his streaming roots I'm not sure
what that means pretty sure he just got
paid did he start on mixer no no mixers
no okay but I so people are saying
obviously got paid a lot of money you
know what I think you should have equity
I think he got equity oh and mixer
because I don't use big stars like this
are gonna shell out millions of dollars
I think the smart way to get him on
board is give them a couple points
because someone like him can make the
platform like no other advertisement
could you know of course look at this
ten million views never heard of mixer
it's owned by Microsoft though do you
think I mean Microsoft I don't know if
they would well there's basically in the
company no no not Microsoft yeah no I
think they would I think they would for
for this it's a smart play mm-hmm give
him give him like yeah well you know
even a quarter of a percentage can end
up being worth a lot of money yeah I
think they totally would because even
though it's owned by Microsoft these
companies don't operate they still have
like standard ways of operating where
they're not gonna drop ten million
dollars yeah cuz they have a balance
sheet and everything I think equity I
mean short of just paying him like you
know 10 million bucks for like a
two-year contractors
something which it's possible but I
think equity I think he got a piece him
coming on their pot farm is worth that
much
totally so I wouldn't be surprised well
somebody back in the day was trying to
court us to join their platform down to
post our videos exclusively on their
platform and they were offering us
equity
yeah but it was but they actually didn't
offer enough for us to for it to be
interesting to be interesting so we
ended up passing and then they went out
of business a month later it's not so
funny it was really funny they were
being so cheap on the equity offer yeah
and then they went out of [ __ ]
business a month later and now for us
looking back it was like what why why
did you guys negotiate so hard yeah they
were like a month away from closing yeah
it's awesome
weird I'm glad I didn't [ __ ] that stupid
ass boy so there you go good for ninja
I'm I'm happy for him [ __ ] twitch we
need competition all-around competition
is good nothing sellout about it I gotta
say to a mixer you know is kind of been
made fun of by the streaming community
is like our Ustream um makes our kind of
thing because it's so small
but in my experience visiting it and
I've been seeing a lot of feedback too
with this ninja thing of people you know
visiting it for the first time in a few
years because ninjas there it's
legitimately really good like the layout
the the website runs really well much
better than twitch you know twitches
website is a joke I don't understand how
they haven't revamped it at this point
are we being paid by mixer when you get
them on board they followed me and then
I checked and they follow like 5,000
people on oh god [ __ ] you I was like
mixer deal equity baby
I'll take 5% mixer is fantastic within
hours of the announcement mixer was
number one on the App Store so whatever
it was worth it yeah you know they must
have been negotiating this deal for a
while though because Dan was telling me
about niche ninja stats recently and he
told me he has he had
fifteen thousand twitch subs down from
his peak when he was like huge of
250,000 Wow but I was like 15,000 how's
that possible that's um that's how much
we had when we were doing it once a week
I was like I don't believe that cannot
be true and I'm book started looking at
a ninja then I guess he just has a lot
of residual Fame I mean he just became
so huge but his stats fell out in a
remarkable way like his average views
were what is the red and blue so the red
is our strength that that's nothing
that's just followers and streamed but
here's his average views so around this
time that's what I remember that it was
at like over a hundred thousand every
time he streamed but recently it's been
down to like you know but this is what I
mean you see that happened on YouTube to
big channels too and then right
something happens and they change it
format or newer one with a new trend and
they pick it up again but you don't just
throw out your well to be fair on the
low end he's getting thirty thousand but
then like on this day he had sixty seven
thousand not so fast
that's a lot but for somehow his
subscribers dropped so dramatically what
is that on here damn yeah it should be
oh yeah oh yeah yeah his subscribers I
don't know how man he's done a small now
but here last month he had 15,000 let's
shock the hell out of me I don't know if
there's just people abandoning twitch
altogether cuz how was it possible he
had 15,000 subs I mean at this point he
had 250,000 that was insane so I don't I
don't blame him either for looking for
greener pastures because dude went from
250 times 3 that's how much he was
making per sub that's 750 thousand
dollars a month you know what I'm saying
that's just subs down to 45 more than oh
yeah 45,000
that's pretty much 100% loss I mean ice
a lot of money however you cut it that's
a lot of guacamole but I don't blame the
guy for looking for greener pastures man
that shocked the hell out of me you have
to you have to always look what's
forward and what's best for you as the
Creator yeah
two hundred and fifty thousand dude yeah
of course
bitrate which pocket which the guy who
was saying that was obviously just
bitter as [ __ ] and scared for his own
job cuz he doesn't want everyone to
leave twitch leave his ass behind and
then on the other hand I was his YouTube
channel was huge on was huge she was
getting at one point look at this chart
he was getting at one point 200 million
views per month and he gained three and
a half million subscribers in one month
and it was like this for a long time and
then now he's down to a hundred thousand
which is good I mean that's still good
but it's like normal 22 million views I
mean so good that's great but it's not
this insanity
you can't keep yeah that's true you
really can't unless you're a beautify
well no beautify doesn't have actually
PewDiePie does have he doesn't have subs
like that he dead he has views like this
they'll see PewDiePie stance he curious
I was actually just looking at his
channel because I was curious with the
point you made 544 million yeah bro what
we're just talking about the ebb and
flow you can see on him too you know he
has periods where I mean obviously this
is the biggest month ever
yeah because about minecraft making that
mine he's having a slow month you know
or last month was slow he only did
650,000 subs but this month track
he's got 1.5 million
are you [ __ ] my tits raw spit on my
tits and [ __ ] them holy God I guess he's
still not at a hundred million yet slow
it's funny it's going super fast and it
feels so slow because he was getting
like a million a day yeah exactly right
I guess you just can't maintain well
here you can see he got this month six
almost seven million that's like a
million a week or two million a week
[ __ ] six hundred million and he
makes that is completely unknown let's
say three I think that's fair gives like
a million not fair it is fair he's got
millions of mid roles in his videos are
super long that's more than fair it's
not like Thwaites when you know exactly
what trustee behind okay but I want
people to understand that on YouTube you
cannot really know I feel I I would he
makes between two and three
CPM Rose it's not one but you gotta
average all the videos that get
demonetised or claimed or whatever point
eight million a month
mmm PewDiePie is [ __ ] crap well
nobody surprised if he was rich yeah but
damn that's a good salary he granny
clearly deserves it he grinds so hard
he's been doing it for so long how's
that [ __ ] not burned how is he I
don't know now he's playing Minecraft
he's got a YouTube superpower bro I yeah
he has a YouTube superpower yes I was it
you know what the [ __ ] Wow
that guy is something else he's a
workhorse he deserves it
if anyone no I didn't say didn't know I
didn't know and I'm not saying you said
otherwise I'm just saying thank you
thank you for Claire just speaking
anyway there's look at look at look at
us but that brings me to my next point
is that there was recently the fortnight
World Cup which was really interesting
there was a 30 million dollar prize pool
largest in eSports of all time even the
losers got 50k so actually that's really
cool cuz usually the losers just [ __ ]
waste their life and get nothing that's
right I mean like let's be honest like
in the dota Championships it's like the
winner gets a million dollars and
everyone else who's games for 20 hours a
day professionally gets nothing
nothing damn win or die trying'
first place was a 16 year old won three
million bucks 16 did has looked it up
the losers do you get something in dota
as well would they get although it's
split dota is a team game so actually it
yeah you split five ways right and then
probably the management gets something
too so yeah it's not it's not that great
well what is it a last place in last
year's dota tournament got 63 grand so
split five ways 10% for management right
exactly yeah it's something that's
enough to live off for a year I could
got 5 grand when I was 18 share a room a
ramen yeah
anyway the six year old kid won 3
million bucks you know when I used to be
super into Starcraft 2 it's always the
young kids that win these games because
once you're like over the age of
20 to your brain is already too slow I
swear to you you have to be you have to
be like a Renaissance freak child
because their reflexes and the way that
they learn they're just insane I've seen
it so many times in Starcraft 2 like 15
16 year-olds world champions 22 year-old
alcoholic
can't hold his own anymore it's actually
true in South Korea they all become
alcoholics
Oh big drinking problem in South Korea
it's kind of like the equivalent of like
the model modeling mmm
career you gotta be on I mean you can't
really be 30 I mean you see it today
more but it's mostly like young girls
mmm
you think they wash up at 30 yeah it's
crazy and gaming they wash up even
sooner I swear to god it's like 22 whoa
dude you weren't lying I just looked it
up South Korea is like per capita the
biggest drinking country in the world
yeah they love a lot yeah they're crazy
drinkers whoa yeah easy yeah you
wouldn't expect it but there it is they
drink Russia Russia's number two what if
they carried some rice some rice based
like beer beverage it's not sake it's
something else
yeah I've never heard of but they love
it you soju so like just to put it in
context ninja and all these other famous
streamers that you know to be like the
best in the world didn't even qualify so
they're not there might be the most
popular but they're not even as close to
as good as the 16 year old kid who by
the way won the tournament by far Wow
like he I guess they gauged it by how
many points you get in each match by how
well you do and he won by like double
the guy in second place that's K so
these they can't even hold a candle to
the six year old kid and ninjas 28 he's
like he's too [ __ ] all yes yeah I'm
telling you he'll never I bet you ninja
will never even make it to the finals
any here because there's just some
six-year-old kid at home was a [ __ ]
plugged in you know here's the video of
him winning by the way which is pretty
much what you'd expect you know look at
take a look at this okay I have a bone
to pick here Philip DeFranco is alive
what the hell is that
since when is he doing live alone I got
a look at this we're gonna do a meadow
of thing here what is this [ __ ]
hi I'm going to delete this on Monday
what is this they're doing some kind of
live stream why is that the title no no
you better watch quick all right
that's such good bait because look on
the on the sidebar I'll show you guys
it's like his normal thumbnail he says
I'm gonna delete this on Monday
different there's always on that
clickbait game well anyway here's the
six-year-old winning three million
dollars and my goodness this is the most
anti-climactic you know they're in this
huge stadium and how many seats didn't
say it had Dan at the twenty three
thousand twenty three thousand Fulda
sold-out stadium watch how anticlimactic
this climactic it is
this game
he's not anti-climatic well he died but
he won anyway so the guy who won the
tournament is anything for the game fire
will see this guy just one look at this
[Applause]
there's no Gatorade there's no family
where's the family in front like bro
yeah it's just getting awkward at this
but you know look at everyone around
congratulating him my god I mean guys
what do we do what is this this is the
biggest sporting event in a row you've
seen NASCAR you know those [ __ ]
celebrate where's the parents he's
looking bears Diaz yeah found it thank
you
like you see NASCAR had those
[ __ ] celebrate trophy crowd
champagne bottle you don't need to get
alcohol get a soda pop and [ __ ] squirt
it on him like all right let's give the
kid a hug you like what is going on here
well there was it there was some sort of
award ceremony right it didn't just end
after that did it well I don't know but
I mean this was the moment but it you're
right I mean you won three million
dollar million dollars this is the big
moment
to be Saturday
you stand there there doing this these
are unbelievable I got to talk to them
great job but congratulations to him but
I got to talk to them no wonder this
starts a whole new genre of annoying
parents who are like are you gonna get
us three million dollars like when the
kid is playing video games I think that
they exist probably well I tell you what
these kids are not they need to play
with the support of their family here's
the crazy thing though will people ever
take 16 year-olds serious because like
in sports the prime is between 18 and
probably even up to 35 because like even
though physically like Kobe was having
his best years when he was like you know
in his 30s right no no late early 30s he
was having good times was he he was
still doing well but I mean when he when
the Lakers were winning every year I
think he was in his early 20s mm-hmm
well I just I don't know that that
people are ever gonna be okay watching
16 year olds because you don't want to
feel like you're watching a bunch of kid
you watch when is it going mainstream
and obviously it's in a stadium you know
there's a lot of Olympic sports where
the athletes are all very young
gymnastics Olympic gymnastics they're
all teenagers but I think they're meant
to be
are they not 18 no I mean the it's
always like at least in the what do you
call it when they're like flipping the
tumbling and all of that those are
always like teenagers
mm-hmm and their same kind of thing as
the eSports they're they're over the
hump by the time they're 18 they're all
news interesting here's some stats by
the way this kid's name is Kyle Booga
Kyle Booga Jarrod arf 16 year old from
[Music]
he took first place in the solo
competition in the inaugural fortnight
World Cup he amassed 59 points with 23
of that coming from eliminations over
the sixth round finals played today that
information was not useful to me stats
this is this is interesting
I was wondering how popular is for
tonight compared to other sports because
you see them here so here let's put it
in perspective
overall for tonight's stats it has 78
million active players 250 million
registered accounts for comparison
League of Legend has 80 million active
players Pub G is down to 750 thousand
not even a million although so this is
when it gets weird pub G Mobile has a
hundred million active players and
they're all China you can play that on
the phone I know isn't that nuts online
peaked at oh so how many people were
watching this tournament two million
people live watching the tournament
between YouTube twitch and all that but
for comparison you're looking at the
World Series of baseball 14 million dota
2 World Championship had 15 million
although four million 14 million were in
China Super Bowl 100 million that's the
biggest sporting event and the United
States
I wonder if once we have adults who grew
up playing these kind of games will day
watch a tournament like that
the problem with eSports and it's always
gonna be the problems that the game
changes oh yeah right no one's gonna
give a [ __ ] about for tonight in like
two years
yeah so that's the problem it is well
legal legend this game has been around
forever
that finals had 205 million 203 million
of it came from China yeah a Chinese
team was in the files which was a big
reason why
but there's so many [ __ ] peep
China we have 300 million here in this
country that's a lot yeah in China what
do they have like 5 billion are like 3
billion I think no no I think it's like
1.5 billion something like that China
population at one point one point four
okay that's a lot that's a lot of dough
I mean 203 million people in China watch
the League of Legends final that's
two-thirds the population of United
States
yeah but here it gets crazy
so to put in perspective the 2018 World
Cup of soccer had 900 million that's
gonna get me anytime soon so
so just for comparison two million
watched fortnight 900 million watch the
world cup of soccer mm-hmm so I just I
don't know that you'll ever be dudes
kicking around the ball simple is the
best there's nothing that misinterpret
there you know what I mean there you
have it I crunched the numbers what do
you think were you fascinated you have
any thoughts I was very fascinated and I
still I'm very upset at that kids
parents
oh you're blaming them yeah
well he won three million bucks yeah we
need to take a break how long has it
been yeah we do yes exactly
okay great so we come back I've got so
much to talk about you guys I mean
please don't go away I've got a new
segment called a pile of goofs where
I've assembled a lot of fun videos that
are too short to watch in its entirety
but group together into a pile is a lot
of fun so guys stick around we'll be
right back if you believe that you're
not being snooped on or that nobody
cares about your online data well I'm
sorry to disappoint you but you're wrong
because you listen to my show you're
clearly smart enough to understand that
your privacy is under attack thank you
for the compliment in your copy read
expressvpn hackers governments and ad
companies and isfp ISPs are gobbling up
your data like all of it that's why I
recommend getting the software
that I trust to protect my online
activity Express repeated their app use
powerful encryption to secure yours and
my data expressvpn runs in the
background of your computer or phone and
then you use the internet just like you
normally would
you download the app click connect and
voila now you're protected I never go
online without expressvpn and you
shouldn't either
if you run 2 VPNs at the same times that
like wearing two condoms where it's less
safe I wear two condoms no I don't know
but I guess don't do it I just once all
you need expressvpn I never go online
with that expressvpn press ppm is the
fastest VPN I've tried cost less than
seven dollars a month and it comes with
a 30-day money-back guarantee expressvpn
uses new cutting-edge technology called
trusted server to make sure there's no
logs of what you do online it's time to
stop the hackers the Big Brother's the
internet companies from gobbling up your
data
take back your online privacy like I did
with expressvpn and right now protect
your online activity today and find out
how you can get three months for free at
expressvpn dot-com / h3 that's expr e SS
VPN dot-com / h3 for three months free
with a one-year package visit expressvpn
com / h3 to learn more about it
you've got a problem all right and it's
nothing to be ashamed about but let's
face it you're going bald
all right the you know most men by age
35 66 percent of them are already going
bald we got to do something about that
you know it's not okay
that every time you take a shower
there's hair coming off your head like a
like a scene from psycho going down the
drain let's stand up together and say no
to baldness take my hand because I've
got the solution for you
it's for hems calm the one-stop-shop for
hair loss skincare and sexual well
that's why bad thanks to science you
guys baldness can be optional hymns
connect you with real doctors medical
grade solutions to treat your hair loss
well known generic generic equivalents
to name-brand prescriptions help you
keep your hair this is the real deal
guys this is prescription solutions
backed by science there's no waiting
room no awkward in-person doctor visits
you're gonna save hours by going to for
hemes dot-com it's so easy guys you go
on to four hams you ask you answer a few
quick questions
doctors will review it and then
prescribe you the medicine you need to
keep that beautiful luscious hair where
it belongs
on your head and not in the frickin
drain stop worrying about the sunblock
on the bald spot of thinning hair and do
something to help your hair loss and
promote hair growth products are shipped
directly to your door right now for our
listeners we got a special deal listen
up get a month trial of hymns for just
five dollars today right now while
supplies last
see website for full details and safety
information guys this would cost
hundreds if you went to the doctor or a
pharmacy so go to forums dot-com slash
h3 that's fo r hims comm slash h3 for
hams com / h3 let's keep that beautiful
hair where it belongs on your head
welcome back my super troopers have you
heard about this story of Saudi Arabia
is building a dystopian cyberpunk city
in the middle of the desert called neo
m-- so like let's name it enlike neo
from the matrix but with them at the end
Saudi Arabia I don't I don't care if
they build a [ __ ] heaven on earth
city where you know I mean I don't know
what heaven is but I will never go to
Saudi Arabia for any reason or Quatar na
Quatar worse Dubai that's in the UAE
yeah [ __ ] those countries I don't I
don't even know how is that what is the
reasoning their governments are insane
like Dubai is was literally built from
slave laborers from Southeast Asia where
they get them there and they take their
passports so they can't leave do you
know there's like so many people died
building the Burj they're just like they
don't give a [ __ ] about human life
they're they're psycho and they have
these crazy they have like Sharia law
they're like what am I gonna go there
I'm not gonna it's like you Rocky and
Sweden they'll just lock you up man you
don't get to say [ __ ] and these
[ __ ] Sharia law like you you oh
oh I accidentally kissed a dude just
known you to death I don't want to go I
don't want to visit a place where if I
accidentally rub my dick on another
guy's dick accidentally I'm gonna get
stoned to death well I'm just saying if
it accidentally happens like oh now I'm
at the end of a noose not town they
don't drink alcohol
[ __ ] that actually they do that's the
thing about them they're so corrupt all
the rich [ __ ] do drink alcohol there
remember when we had the call from the
guy yeah great guy it was great he was
no I'm sure the people are are wonderful
but the government's like they set this
whole Saudi royalty not to mention like
in Saudi Arabia they just killed
they literally just murdered a
journalist yeah who lived in the United
States yeah and everyone's like cool
let's go visit the cyberpunk place no I
don't trust them because you go there
and they'll walk you up they'll murder
you for anything they want that's pretty
scary not down it is scary if you go
there you have to put a turn of [ __ ]
t-bob on that females are allowed to
drive right that's new yeah apparently
in Saudi Arabia although there's also
reports that of at the same time female
activists being like silently
disappearing in the night bye-bye that's
awful what do you call the thing the the
shawl that women have to wear a burqa
another burke is the full-body one
what's oh you job a job you have to wear
a hijab you want to go wear hijab um I
can buy that Gucci one Gucci the black
oh yeah you won't you won't draw
anything I want I don't want to subject
my wife to wear a hijab because I want
to go visit Dubai do you have to do that
yes
it's illegal for women to not cover
their hair in Dubai I thought and Dubai
there they're a little bit more relaxed
I think you're right about Saudi Arabia
so what the [ __ ] what am I gonna do
gonna vote the rules don't apply in this
city if they if if they feel like it yep
pretty much I mean that's the case with
this new thing to the the cyberpunks in
here well you're gonna have alcohol
there alcohol the rules won't apply why
what is it what's the rules why do they
not apply in this city not down dude I
do not like it and I'm not saying that
because they're Muslim because you know
Indonesia for example doesn't stone gay
people as far as I'm aware they're the
biggest Muslim company and they were
allowed there No yes yeah but regardless
I don't like any of that [ __ ]
no but yeah I do
I I steal a point I just think you
should make it clear and yeah I think
you did that you don't have a problem
with the people what do I know about the
people there's a lot of people who live
there why don't rule yes we love the
people we love the people best people
they have the best people in Saudi
Arabia
especially in United and United you
United Arab Emirates is that right that
is correct I love all them in the name
of the country I love all the Southeast
Asians who are locked up like actual
slaves and their passports taken away
from them sick so epic they're not
allowed to drive or go home oftentimes
aren't even paid and they're sent to
build buildings and fall to their death
SoDo yeah yeah well anyway let me tell
you about this dystopian city city was
announced in 2017 should be at the
northwest corner of the country adjacent
to the Red Sea on the border of Egypt
and Jordan right now it's completely
barren desert the proposal for phormium
was dreamt up by team of us-based
consultants and management firms The
Wall Street Journal discovered that
Boston Consulting Group yada-yada-yada
we're working on the project here let me
throw you five hundred billion dollar
project includes flying taxis sorry
since when is that a thing
maybe hot-air balloons I don't know
flying taxis robot maids beaches with
glow-in-the-dark sand that sounds
[ __ ] sick cloud seeding to bring rain
to the city does that technologist yeah
cloud Syria here
where the [ __ ] do they cloud seed they
it's they use some sort of like silver
nitrate or some chemical but yeah they
disperse it into the atmosphere and it
causes the moisture in the upper
atmosphere to coalesce and turn into
rain clouds so
I mean it's a real that's an effective
way of creating yeah I think they even
did it over California a few years ago
when we were in the height of the big
drought that we had been having for like
allocate here yeah I think they they
[ __ ] around with it a little bit what
yeah that's pretty wild hologram
facilities teaching and hologram
teachers is that what I'm reading that
doesn't sound very good
yeah like a school teacher it's like you
know skyping in a teacher but instead of
Skype it's a hologram that doesn't sound
like a feature that sounds like really a
nightmarish thing I was all agree I'm
gonna teach a class security handled by
24/7 mask facial recognition
surveillance in a massive police drone
presence great wow that's exciting
a robot dinosaur Island Romo was this
dreamt up by 12 year old yeah robot cage
fighting so Dan was telling me about
this it's blood sports like ancient Rome
how they had gladiators fight it's like
that but robots alright fair we have
battle bots here I guess it's really
well battle bots is like a couple of
nerds with a remote control this sounds
like a Coliseum oh yeah that's that's
the first one that sounds cool you know
what's what's American gonna happen this
is what happens in Saudi Arabia you get
two criminals to dress up like a robot
and they just you're actually just
watching people kill them kill each
other you know what I mean it's just a
costume
yeah they just have like a really
high-level outfit them you think they're
robots but if they're actually just
doing another state of the art medical
facilities where scientists will work to
modify the human genome to make people
stronger oh alright
why do why is that going on here
anywhere cool why is that a poor like
you got your you guide me at flying
taxis and beaches with glowing Sam
then I'll soon you're hitting me with
mass facial
cognition surveillance and robot police
and human genome modifying but the sand
glows in the dark
this one is [ __ ] cool I have to say
an artificial moon that would be lit up
and we can do elite of drones if we can
do send glowing in the dark we should do
it everywhere mm-hmm we need smart
stance and standard Bluetooth and dude
this city first of all will never happen
and second of all if it did it would be
such a [ __ ] show it's gonna be such a
[ __ ] show there's no way that this could
ever work everything would be breaking
it would look all ghetto look up here
kind of carnival thing yeah could be so
ghetto and then this is gonna be like
the craziest ghost town after one year
when everyone stops going cuz it's just
so stupid and they're like check out the
robot mate and it's just like you put
your face and just does that to you
hang-hang robot we don't want a glass of
water what is it do do ela wipes your it
would just wipe your breath oh thank you
robot maid I don't know man these that's
like Saudi Arabia bro this is another
another problem I have with this country
they became rich tellurium lock and now
what are they doing with this money
building the stupid 500 billion dollar
project well to be fair I think from my
understanding they're doing this because
they they're well aware that they're
gonna run out of oil eventually and they
they got to make themselves something
other than just an oil country this
ain't the way to do this is not this is
not a good investment if it's if the
purpose is an investment also it's it's
it hinges on people actually wanted to
go to saw
Rabia which i think most people from
Western culture would never want to go
to Saudi Saudi Arabia is [ __ ] crazy
dude
people cut damn heads off there they
have like they have like religiously
there dude have you seen all those crazy
rich Saudi Arabia kids on YouTube like
yeah just buy a Lamborghini cash mm-hmm
that's pretty crazy yeah bro it's it is
crazy you know what happens to a country
that was made super rich by dumb luck
like all of a sudden that money's gonna
go away and all but they're gonna be
left with this glow-in-the-dark sand no
that's a good and I don't know what's
gonna happen to that region it's gonna
be crazy how are they gonna make taxis
fly Dan that's a good question I mean
involved gonna build that maybe they're
they're trying to I mean we've been
promised [ __ ] flying cars since like
the 60s so maybe they're you know
they're just trying to finally make it
happen they're trying to deliver on that
promise doesn't it seem just so messy
like now they actually think about yeah
taxis falling out of the sky once there
however they fly it's gonna fall garbage
is gonna fall pieces of cars are gonna
fall so you can't be under it first of
all it's too dangerous
mm-hmm second of all you what's the
point of flying
I guess cuz you could do like straight
lines but so that's why a long musk was
talking about with the boring company he
says you can do that underground that
makes a lot more sense instead of flying
you a straight line underground and you
go a lot faster underground on a track
yeah and it's not a danger also just
look so ugly to see like such a mess in
the air all the time we're in it I'd
imagine the cloud - yeah and then the
noise pollution that's that's another
thing that you awful the noise - to make
an actual taxi that could support human
weight
would the propulsion would have to be so
powerful it would be deafening with our
current technology you know so there you
have it I'm going for that robotic
Cagefighting
we're sending on the end you're gonna be
one of the robots if ya don't look at it
don't believe other rules dude Ian I'm
sending you out there I want you to [ __ ]
a dude and see what happens you ant we
can negotiate that Oh to sting
well I'd go for the genome messing with
my genomes you want to be stronger so
okay let me if I did you a surgery to
make your dick like 20 feet long
would you sounds like and you got to use
it in the arena I'm gonna make you a
giant big bazooka to fight in the arena
all right you ready for this pile of
goofs big old pile of them huh all right
I got a pile of goofs here these I've
been collecting for a while and these
are all nice little clips that I love on
its own not that great together a
powerful wonderful segment from the
beginning we start with an McBaine the
elevates to levels never before seen 16
pound whole alligator you know like
we've seen everything and I'm not I
don't get disturbed very easily anymore
I can watch like we watched Fear Factor
while we eat a lot yeah yeah you know
yeah I cannot watch this video this is
the one video that I can't watch so this
is worse than the crab you have a whole
cooked I think is the worst video on
town mate you know it's all whole it's
like this has been a flick to to level
might not be this it is quite disgusting
the music might not be okay
so I think it's free but yeah and we are
celebrating a hundred so much not what
she's done by God so is anyone else
feeling what I'm feeling
no it's auras gusting so she's got a
huge Gator with a lemon in his mouth no
I cannot believe this thing smells so
good it smell it
let me we're gonna get into it guys I
have a 15 pound alligator that was made
for me I told ya you listening has to
understand it's a whole alligator with a
lemonade mouth and covered in glass yes
it was like a barbecue restaurant
downtown at the guild hotel it's called
Luca Luca is beautiful I love going
there the staff is so by the way I got
about it oh she's basting it angry sick
[ __ ] to see it like she's just no so
we're not she can't get into the skin we
found out about the big lobster stuff we
found out other people were doing it is
this something that other people have
done I think she was trying to find
something unique to celebrate 100,000
she did so she didn't really eat
anything did she she didn't put it down
oh no this is an apex predator this is a
predator at the top of his game jaws
that can clamp down with ten billion
forces of pressure
this alligator live valiantly fighting
for survival and here he sits on this
dumbasses table with a lemon in his
mouth with a blue microphone hey daddy
look how much she ate by the time I go
to the end that's it it looks the same
this is the end of the video oh my god
he's gonna throw that thing out what was
the point of this video then she didn't
even eat anything but she didn't even
eat any from the side that's facing the
camera that's what bothers me
so it was exactly the same clearly not
eating it she don't like it yeah how
could you like that okay next time you
delegate her you got to go to the swamp
no worse video I have ever seen
yeah ever you can show me anything else
what what she's asking for a share would
you share please she's begging my
friends and family one day dear mom she
begged me I cannot believe that she does
she destroyed it this beautiful predator
for like a clickbait title I just
googled it to see if other people have
done it with alligator and they have but
not in none of these other videos is it
just like a whole [ __ ] animal sitting
on the table you know it's like it's
fried up and just in pieces or something
they had to humiliate it in death tube
by putting the lemon in his mouth you
know thing about it is so insane like
what is wrong with you in fact this is
the levels of Logan Paul going to the
suicide forest it's just like thinking
oh it's a good idea for video and
forgetting completely about what it
means what does it mean I don't know I
don't did everything that you've
described is so horrible I don't want to
see this alligator like that on her
stupid table covered in this disgusting
black sauce I love how she basted it
with and then she doesn't even eat it
she if she didn't eat any of it 30
minutes she didn't even dent it like at
least let me see you like I can't find
her eating any to be fair it's 16 pounds
of meat
I know but she didn't even try to make
it look like well she knew that starting
out it's not like she's got people over
she's just her she's right down the meat
looks crazy
the meat looks like raw chicken I feel
like she doesn't like it she's right no
[Music]
bro I do not understand let's talk about
VidCon well there's a Dalek there's no
plan you just eat the food and then talk
about elliegator on your table there's a
whole alligator in front of you social
anxiety after I get my schedule together
yeah
she's dancing with a black mayor episode
I don't like want to mess it up like
mess up the whole oh but we want to see
what it looks like eaten isn't that the
whole point of the MOOC bang yeah I
think it's tail she doesn't to eat it
cuz there's too much fat in the tail so
she's she's going over to the ribs she's
peeking
you have a 16-pound do you see how like
particular she is Dan yes she's peeking
in like it's a wallet look he's going in
all the sound effect oh my god
oh my gosh and this is literally like
it's a bunch of you she's eating the
skin it's like gnarly flavor so that we
don't linger um I swear to God that the
meat looks like raw chicken weird I
looked it up I guess
alligator tastes like quail oh I know a
quail tastes like sure and quail tastes
like Wamba what's that
I don't know tastes like one book who
knows what who eats quail
kind of reference point is that tastes
like poop Illini got alligator one time
tell me Dad they on a cruise ship once
tell me about it
I mean it tasted kind of chicken dish
was it did they serve a whole alligator
on your plate no they kind of ripped me
off there I think did that did you enjoy
it I mean I didn't mind it it was
alright mmm okay thanks for chiming in
Ian thank you I appreciate the
opportunity we don't hear from you a lot
these day well you didn't need to make
powerpoints so we have heard from you
recently which is nice I don't want
anyone to think we have beef or anything
just because the PowerPoint didn't
sweetie ate some waves oh I forgot to
talk about yeah how did I miss so skip
over that I don't know I totally missed
that hold on so let me finish this and
then I'll go back okay talk about that
I'm gonna stay on message here anyway I
don't know why this video is giving me
such a feeling but I'd hate it I know I
I totally catching about it is it
significantly worse to you than the
giant crab yes hmm I think I think
they're equally gross I think it's
interesting I think probably because
it's it alligator and I don't know
they're so cool it's a whole alligator
with his head and tail and it's all
covered in this black one and also she
at least the other girl with the giant
lobster tried to get in beast mode and
eat it that's true this girl had like
two
blow nibbles well I mean like also I've
seen people you'd lobster it's just way
bigger which was apparently in the South
they [ __ ] what they eat alligator yeah
but you do you ever serve like the whole
alligator on the table yeah that's
standard
no that's buffet Sunday no I'm kidding
I'm sure that's that's totally that's
crazy
here's something to cheer you up the
French army proud of our army modern and
innovative the Prime Minister of France
tweeted out if you need to know why
France loses every war here it is
they've got some homie on a hoverboard
with a gun in his hands look at this
[ __ ] this is the dumbest [ __ ] you've
seen in your life I mean I know it's
full but to actually say I proud of our
army modern and anime innovative i dude
if you send that in to war this is like
a huge epic moment he's like peace I'm
out I only have enough fuel for two
minutes just in and out in like second
you can hear him flying off that was him
that smoke he detonated I mean it looked
fun it was a instrument of war it's the
dumbest thing I've ever seen so proud of
our army innovative and modern
dude I think bro I wouldn't I wouldn't
send that in the combat it's all loud
he's on the table what is that yeah wow
that is think about the taxi we're
talking yeah yeah look at this thing
done
you have to stabilize before you can
chew you'd be killed like immediately
he's like you up Carol no one else has
dudes on hoverboards flying into combat
this guy trained for like two years for
this hmm
epic truly magnificent I would love to
see that turned into a sport or
something somehow I mean the thing is
cool that's an instrument of war Dan
yeah hilarious
now Jets that makes more sense he's
still crushing it though yeah nice proud
of our modern military people were
goofing cuz it was like green goblin
like from spider-man but yeah I love to
see a fleet of those okay half of them
will crash into each other
yeah the other half will be shot down
before they equalize enough to shoot so
there's the French army our stay on the
good side of France people fupa army is
taking our hate of KFC a little too far
look at this video
[ __ ] KFC exploded in North Carolina
do you see that what happened you know I
have a cynical for it it looks almost
comic book he like how much it exploded
it shows a KFC at night someone's
filming it for some reason or actually
sorry someone's filming a TV screen
efforting is secured it's just security
yeah so yeah certainly
but I'm so cynical of KFC I almost feel
like this is viral marketing nobody was
hurt it's just a KFC exploding like
literally they probably needed to
remodel that branch anyway hmm although
I can't it's not really a great look
where it's like hey come in a KFC could
explode at any minute so there you go I
thought that was worth sharing the idea
that it it might have been an
overzealous h3 fan taking the I don't oh
yes I'm dismissing them right off face
value this was fantastic you this is a
bit old but somebody sent in an attack
drone in Brazil on a party that was
being too loud we can hear the sound on
this one no I don't think they're sound
it's a gift oh but it yeah wish we did
have sound but it's a drone with a
firework attached to it like a roman
candle and he's just sniping on
everybody and it's pretty awesome
no running range army look at this yeah
French army take note France first
Brazil epic of warfare god bless we've
got more here guys but this is a pile of
goofs this one came in China this [ __ ]
only ever happens in China dude a freak
tsunami at a wave pool in China
like in the kiddie pool dude the wave
pool in China there's tsunamis even in
the wave pool look at this [ __ ] [ __ ]
amazing their wave pool is usually the
chillest look at this nobody died but I
guess for four people were injured look
at this
apparently the wave mechanism
malfunction it just launched like a dead
like a freaking tsunami dude China is so
crazy man I feel like this would only
ever happen there I want to watch that
again oh stop the autoplay all right I'm
over it okay now I can't believe I
missed over this so during a ins
PowerPoint presentation we had discussed
if little NAS was guilty of copyright
infringement he was accused of another
rapper little Tracy vert mi Rio Doce his
name no art no Burt oh just a little
traceable Tracy that's a different guy
oh he's not the Burt Busey mm-hmm
right yeah that's right so his name is
little Tracy by the way everyone same
little these days you know that
everyone's look my rap name would be
Lolo little big no you can be little big
I'm Lolo I've already been a little
client mmm
so he tweeted at me did that shocked the
hell out of you when you saw that Ian no
I mean he seems very plugged in online
but it still is funny but you're making
waves dude you made a PowerPoint talking
about this and the next day we've got
Tracy little trace tweeting at me he
said keep my name out your mouth grandpa
and then heat and then he tagged me was
interesting about it is they blocked the
pod kept our actually he let me put
sunscreen so here keep your name out I'm
out your mouth grandpa
um how old is little Tracy it's a good
question let's look it up he's a young
man
early twenties probably and he was
what's interesting he's preemptively
blocked the podcast Twitter but he never
blocked me it's 23 and so everyone's
trying to I I just I sent a bunch of
laughing emojis because I thought it was
hilarious and I retweeted him because I
love whenever we're talking has like
real world
influence I think it's incredible and
then he quote tweeted my laughing emojis
with a serious face like I'm dead
serious
so I so I responded to him I said is
this what beef is you know am I in rat
beef right now that's pretty crazy for
me in you were getting lots of [ __ ] in
the comments bro have Tracy on so we can
explain Ian's got a load of [ __ ] Rome
these people are wild and I don't know
what they're talking about here's the
clip from four minutes on was pretty
pissed when I heard it was just
listening the podcast normally and he
got he got super angry I want one of
them to elaborate just one I was looking
I wanted them to prove me wrong once
said why are you so angry and he
responded because I'm a Tracey fan and I
feel like he didn't have full context
but to begin with we didn't even talk
[ __ ] about a little Tracey we all like
the song well I actually Ian said he
preferred it yeah the only thing I said
that I can think would have upset him
was that I thought he should have been
more chill with little nod yeah but oh
and I didn't take little nods copied him
mm-hmm
do you think that's what I said that
yeah I mean you effectively said tough
luck you know which whatever I mean well
now I'm an internet well now I'm in rap
beef but I see these people criticizing
Ian and like he and said they didn't say
what he got wrong first of all second of
all let's see them put on such a great
PowerPoint yeah
I'd like to see a counter PowerPoint
yeah what if I want to see what kind of
effects they do in PowerPoint they don't
want the smoke they don't got the slides
you know I love if Ian had like an
arch-nemesis that came in with the
counter power PowerPoint
Ethan has an advert h3 podcast listener
fan Ian had absolutely no idea what he
was talking about when he came to little
Tracy let him explain himself get Tracy
on the show how am I gonna get Tracy on
the show we have we have beef now he
gave me the straight face when I laughed
and I said is this what beef is and then
he tweeted out old white men quickly
erased it
you know whenever someone calls me old I
have two inclinations I go well I'm only
34 but then that steps my self up where
they're like dude you look like you're
50 I'm not I'm not insulted by it when
someone calls me old either uh and then
he said oh yeah and then he sent me this
I said is this what beef is and he just
sent me a picture of his profile picture
which is like a de nom demonic rabbit
and I said spooky and he raised it again
though I don't know I I don't know if I
wanted to be four and then I sent him
this which he didn't he back down all
the sudden go cowardly once he saw what
he was up again this is a picture of
beef you don't want and I sent him a
picture of my under foolish shot and all
the sudden he got real quiet he wanted
to talk [ __ ] and then he got real quiet
when he saw what he was up against you
know I just don't get why he's mad when
the whole point of the segment was to
call attention to the fit in you know
percent of people that know the little
na song don't even know who this guy's
is well it wasn't a favor it wasn't a
favorable report to him we were
defending world knows we we don't think
that little nose copied this song really
fired but if your little Tracy he's
saying y'all this guy copying me [ __ ]
him and we're saying well we don't think
so
so we're disagreeing with them yeah so
nothing like you would want to start
beef with us I suppose I then I'm just
saying if you want to end beef look at
that face and see where it ends I can't
see where that exact exactly that's the
mentality that we're working on so I
thought that was pretty thrilling that I
just thought that was really amazing
that that we actually got to engage with
low trace based on the ins PowerPoint so
how fun is that
and and then well then there was a
really exciting follow up I said Ian the
intern making waves and then Gabi here
said is he single is he still single he
said and I said yes Gabi and very
eligible and apparently she D amped him
on Instagram that right Ian I mean I
haven't answered yet but it's there what
did she say like Ethan told me you're
single and I'm like that and so she can
see that you read it and didn't reply
reply no cuz it's in my request okay so
you didn't open it no I know I'm exposed
no you don't know that's unsolicited
well I think anyone who wants to apply
oh boy has to go through lies yeah I
mean if what you're gonna cut out the
middleman if we're if they're coming
because of us we need to vet them if
you're in I don't want to I don't want
you to meet someone who's not you know
look not gonna appreciate your part
points if you're interested send your
resume to podcast at h3h3 productions
comm with a picture a little bit about
it needs to be approved by mommy and
daddy come on can we edit that out
and for those reasons
okay send in your resumes and and let's
let's say no one has to read this yes
you have to date them
don't [ __ ] them we'll do you next in
that's exciting
yeah but is it yeah I got I let a big
stick boy what else we got cursed tik
toks Jimmy Lee oh my god we're actually
gonna finish everything we're gonna be
caught up here Kirstie okay there's a
there's a titter a titter Ethan come on
I'm so tired you guys I'm so [ __ ]
tired yeah I was saying I threw Ethan
that I feel so brain-dead I woke up so
early today to take care of the adang
and he's just so he's sometimes he was
good this morning but yesterday was
brutal yeah what was going on he was
having gas all day and that's so hard
like father like son
I'm just waiting I'm just praying from
the grow out of this phase right now I
don't see any like end in sight it has
improved a lot I guess so you know but
I'm starting to like it's starting to
catch up on me you know cursed tik-tok
there's a twitter handle that i started
following recently that have become
quickly a huge fan of called cursed tic
TOCs and he this this man spends all day
on tick tock enduring the worst it has
to offer and he curates it for our
pleasure so I just been following him
and I ear ear marks my favorite ones
unfortunately they
have copyrighted music so we're gonna
have to act fast
okay I'm you did back here again okay
good so I'll tell you what Connie is
explained now I gotten a lot of trouble
from Indians Indian members of India for
saying that
I think Bollywood is goofy they said
Ethan how the [ __ ] can you say that
about Bollywood that it's goofy how dare
you you don't understand well this is
the kind of thing you see and I admit
that it's a cultural difference I think
this is cool to a lot of people I think
it's goofy can I just say that these
guys are goofy and it's kinda it's got
that Bollywood bot by it I'm trying to
be for the whole country here instead of
just making fun of these two
knuckleheads but do you see what I'm
saying I feel like I feel like so let me
describe what I'm seeing there's two
guys they go from what they jiggling
their heads and go and Criss crossing
and they're crying on one end and then
smiling on the other the guy in the back
kills me look at how he cries like this
one and then the smile and the cry their
tears coming down their face yeah wish I
could play the music thank you Dan thank
you you see what I'm saying
but being on edge the people who got
upset things that you have a problem
with the whole of India yeah that's true
I do know your dog right by the way
people totally misinterpret what I said
cuz I said dude looked like a janitor
and they're like oh all Indian action
stars look like janitors what I meant is
that in an action star movie here in
America they look like the rock and
every [ __ ] movie yeah and that guy
was just he looked very
casual he didn't look very different he
was dressed I didn't say he looks like a
janitor I don't mean all Indian people
look like Jan yeah there's a lot of I
got a lot of [ __ ] for my father you know
that's probably a choice poor choice of
occupation could have said like a
manager at an Applebee's or something
thank you that would have been much
better to say I I frankly didn't even
know there I didn't know there was a
stereotype that any people are janitors
that's not the stereotype if there is
well that's what they were saying
Oh way to describe Indian dudes as
janitors okay okay here you want the
stereotype he looks like the manager at
a call center is that better I mean I
don't know what are they saying why I'm
not I don't mean I don't think any
people are janitors got heartburn you
know what I mean I do know what you mean
I gotta say I gotta stand up for those
Bollywood movies a little bit not that
I'm like a super fan but they're goofy
there for sure goofy but really
entertaining I know I didn't say I
didn't like them or they're not
entertaining
I said Indian people are goofy all of
them 100% of them all of them without
exception are goofy from the prime
minister all the way down now you're
confusing can I not say that I don't
like any Indian person just [ __ ]
around just give me a break just enjoy
the show look at these guys man they're
so good awesome they're really good at
it though like there ya go and
everything I mean I think it's there
really counts and I love how passionate
they're the head jiggles [ __ ] epic we
should do something like that what
they're actually crying how a pig is
that it's cursed but it should be
blessed
this is so epic you see I commented do
you see I don't yeah why anyway India
India YouTube is already tied to destroy
me so they can't touch me now me against
India World War three I think they're
great they're so entertaining
they're fantastic I love Indian people I
do love Indian people out of the best
you're confusing I'm just kidding what
do I care about people I don't care
about them as much as anyone Yeah right
great food Zak said that's racist I love
Indian food people I don't want people
to misinterpret what you're saying why
do you love Indian people so much you
have a fetish I'm just goofing around
and what show the few Indian people that
I know are awesome so that is what I'm
referring to
dude Indian people [ __ ] rule a new
food is delicious and some of the most
bright and best and the plot of this
planet come from India okay
full stop here this is a curse tick tock
I don't remember what song he's singing
but it's some soggy dancing one
apparently fur oh it's uh I remember
it's uh what is it Wham waking you up
before you go go yeah wake me up before
you go-go and it's some homie with a
rope apparently this is that a lot of
furries are branching out to more
lifelike buddy with more lifelike what
yeah teachers from from the cat's
trailer that this the furry community
would reject this guy yeah portunities
not cute
so no but I think what they didn't like
about that one is that they also had
human characters in their face that's
where this one they're like well he
looks like an animal so I'm gonna [ __ ]
him let's suck his dick he looks like an
animal but I look I just the way it's
sped up is it looks like really oh
you're coming to the hotel yeah just I
said this is the most cursed tick-tock
and on the Indian when I said this is
epic so you know and being human I don't
think this one is the most cursed really
it really spooked me in the way he moves
and like I don't know really suits me
personally got the picture-in-picture
and [ __ ] that one doesn't disturb you
know okay how about this one EULA this
one I had to double take I was like I
don't see anything wrong and then you
realize it's homie out of gasoline just
pouring gasoline everywhere that's
cursed yeah you're damn common this is
this is fake why is this fake then
explain to me why this is he's holding a
hose behind the thing or something bro
yes I'm right yes I knew it because yeah
you're totally right
well it's possible that they do fooled
us no that's epic okay so that's a
blessed tick-tock that's a plastic dog
right there okay there you go damn
ruining the fun I'm sorry
nice caroline's me of the Zoolander
thing wait and in that scene in
Zoolander is set to the wham song the
same song it all connects
mm-hmm well okay so this one I think I
can play volume on yeah this one's that
big can i play volume on this one
I don't remember what the music wasn't
this no it's just a picture of a guy
almost like an under job he's looking
down at the camera looking for a tik-tok
wife best do it gets to be my tick-tock
wife gets to be and he's just stupidly
on at the camera and he's got like
Fromm's on his lips and beside ways hat
you got to see this one I'm sorry I
can't really describe it I love that
look to the side can you go back is this
guy's Twitter handle just cursed tick
tock Kristen yeah it's toxic tic TOCs
but it says cursed
tick tock so toxic toxic
what do you say what do you want to see
here just at the audio Lagos if they
want to see you'll definitely go visit
this look is epic I'll be your wife back
I'll sing a duet with you don't look you
got to download Tik Tok man so this one
no I don't want to I just I want I need
a curated so this one is awesome this
this is definitely something to behold
here
I got I can unmute for this one so it's
a one with purple hair click off looking
she has like 30 necklaces on because
they [ __ ] mister exit' and then
[ __ ] chase me down
turn around [ __ ] throw goddamn soda at
me and when I somehow I feel like
tacomas not the problem here
I don't know why this is a tick tock
what makes this a tick tock but I just
love that for some reason this is what
goes on on big dog tick tock award yeah
most curse
tick tock of the year love love love
that she left out the baseball bat until
the end of story develops every time
yeah you've learn more like yeah yeah
it's like Mentos wide if I cut her off
and then it's like so wide if I had a
bad
it wasn't even a footlong yeah I loved
it I love how she goes so shoot me cuz I
wanna die so I pick why is dear white
people trending yeah I saw that I hate
that title I don't care what you care
it's this show you can address white
people as much as I can't say that I
hate every Indian person which I don't
and I would never say that let's move on
I'm just yanking your change you know on
him I'm a peaceful guy I love everyone
yeah never heard yank the chain that's
the thing right guys
huh coming up yeah I mean messing with
you okay I've got the insult manifest
I've been putting this off cuz it's it's
like a long video there's a lot to chew
on there and I've got Jimmy Lee let's
end on Jimmy Lee Jimmy Lee friended the
show you all remember him he's a funny
guy he's a funny guy
he has emailed me basically we had him
on a while ago we collab with him on our
second channel like years years years
ago and he has never stopped sending me
emails just for example here's it says
of about a hundred emails in the top
right so this was I took this screenshot
a couple weeks ago and but you can see
pretty much every week consistently like
200 live 5th June 22 June 21 June 20
June 10 June 6 May 30 May May 18 Wow
but I mean of about a hundred so this
guy that's a hundred weeks he's been
emailing me so here's the new video he
sent me he says he forwarded it to me
comedy reality TV dangerously funny at
Comic Con so like all right let's see
what Jimmy is up to you know I mean I
don't look at his content in a while so
here he is that comic-con tell me if you
guys think his you've improved
Jerzy al-manar comedy reality television
show dangerously funny
we're here in comic-con and fill the
content with all the geeks all the
freaks
yeah yes Philadelphia Pennsylvania these
guys have conquered comic-con one day
they're going to conquer basic hygiene
let's hear for these guys right now
friendless overweight losers friendless
there's there's five of them that I
don't have five friends and they're also
really all skinny yeah
friendless overweight Jimmy we're
talking about the roast let me tell you
you guys should be proud of yourself how
many people can say they're gonna
remember the first time they got
gonorrhea in Philadelphia let's hear it
so he also just said that they're
getting sex too cuz gone ariza STD yeah
that's dope
anyway sorry focus on the comedy you'll
be able to tell your kids or whoever you
take to your a a meeting with dice
dungeons and jury enjoy this is a
wonderful product back in 1962 it's
irrelevant no one gives a [ __ ] about it
because you're decent looking you may
sell a couple dice if the odds are
against it okay you got a play diaas
between you go to the racetrack okay now
snap out of it pack your bags up and get
your crap out of here what did you think
about those jokes where was the joke he
was just like super mean I love it he's
like listen nobody yeah now is that
comedy or what we love Jimmy the comic
books when I was a kid then I turned
nine
you put oh my god he's killing it it's
ten minutes of this dangerously funny
pick-up will be your second date you
look good what happened what is
absolutely nothing Wow
what's your name so here he goes it's
kind of hard to make out what but I
think what's going on is that he's
approaching this black dude like he's a
scary dangerous criminal because he's
black and so I think that's the context
of this interaction Nick Fury whatever
you say anything you say direct wherever
you want to eat anything you want you
want to call your broad anything you
want up there and you're a remarkable
person fury you keep telling yourself
that I disagree you've said it share
like could we
I like threesomes now these are time
he's a mega let me explain something to
here with threesome Tamizh two chicks
and a guy anyway you're thinking all
right I didn't know they came in pairs
it's really nice this is a nice outfit
Halloween will be here soon just keep it
on you
hasil Verne and Shirley alright what's
your line wasn't up to date reference
every time the director hollows action
you take your clothes off you don't
think I know about you oh yeah you were
in that church so I think you can suck
what's that you you're alright what do
you do I gotta find another line of work
you don't know how could she is that
editing what do you do
I am a I'm the president I don't find it
another line of work I thought you were
Elton John don't let your son go down on
me
the manager is you got the job sit back
I'll bring your shrimp cocktail whatever
you want who's a lady
your girlfriend wife you share Josh what
are you doing what are you doing Josh
with the managers like that I want to
know about it how many peanut M&Ms did
you eat today
Oh about thirty hundred you know in the
free love always free love that free
ribs hey me why no free reps anyway you
get the idea it's it's it's a challenge
it's a watch it's a challenge to get
through it
I love Howie's his technique is just to
go to comic-con just like be a dick
that's a zombie style yeah it's it's an
interesting approach I mean certainly
unique I'm here let's watch this one
Batman Batman I want to tell you
something Batman
yeah you're no Caped Crusader or you're
more like a gay crusader where is the
joke it doesn't even rhyme caped and gay
like it's not even a play on words man
yeah you're no Caped Crusader or you're
more like a gay crusader go home uh suck
your own thumb and by that way Batman
yeah
put the mask up a little bit more I've
always looked up to you are you English
would eat the goddamn muffins for
Christ's sake they taste wonderful
what bus accident were you anyway you
get the idea to win today listen nicely
the meth lab to let you out for the day
you want to go skinny-dipping later yeah
that's nice take your clothes off
everybody's going to run for the hills
thank you Jesus what's going on with
this guy he's just off the rail he
really is off the rail I'm surprised he
hasn't been choked out man ones are good
you know why they get on top they're
light they don't hurt okay so listen
what's the joke they care why isn't
there like they don't I'm over it anyway
if you get that yeah Jimmy leave a
jersey outlaw everyone still got it
noticeably less fat jokes those were the
ones that always got me you only made
fun of one fat person but it used to be
like he went up to a big girl and he
said you're a big girl you're a big girl
I've ever got well okay
the only way to follow this episode up
is to have Andrew yangon for president
[Laughter]
people can get angry at me for saying
we're talking about India again I was
trying to help and you want to help me
when I know but like it's you know I
mean I should be able to say that a
whole country people are good for you I
don't know what's wrong with that I
don't actually believe that I want to
apologize to all of our Indian fans and
friends I think you're terrific I think
you're great people an important country
so much
so much culture so much value has come
out of out of your great country your
great land the entertainment top-notch
the people fantastic the food to die for
Indian is without a doubt my favorite
country I regret ever having to say to
speak badly on India is to speak badly
on humanity as a whole I would never
dream of saying anything I hope I hope
that our next Sun is Indian you know if
you want to [ __ ] Indian do it and get
pregnant by him I'm cool with that
no we don't know the music is Indian Oh
if those okay listen if those guys
aren't Indian I'm a racist I accept you
know what I accept it anyway I'm a
racist alright that's getting clipped
cancel me I'm done anyway I'm ready to
retire can't do me a favor and cancel me
my throat it started well when I talk a
lot it gets so I have issues like I was
singing to Theodore all morning to calm
him down that or D get my throat going
and I have a new tic where I like or no
that's not what it is what is it it's
not I forgot what it oh like that I keep
doing that that [ __ ] up my throat but
just talking for two hours and I was up
early so I need to be more careful with
my throat cuz it gets really feel it's
very painful right now I think all the
coughing I do cuz it acid reflux doesn't
help I'm a mess
is the music playing down it is okay in
the contrast of the very cheery theme
song but I'm excited it's Friday yeah
and I am very excited to have Andrew
Yangon I am excited to be involved in
our political process and to discuss
with Andrew a vision area some that I
that I'm having more and more respect
for every day sit here at our blessed
table and discuss the important issues
I'm gonna show them that tick-tock and
asking what he thinks about it I'm gonna
do this with them anyway that's it t ji
f baby thank God it's Friday have a
great great weekend you guys without you
I am nothing
you understand that without you I would
be literally what would I be doing I
don't want it to mean other people's
jobs because I have respect for everyone
that works but basically I wouldn't be
doing this I'd be doing something else
and the song's ending point is that I
love you and if your dick is was ever
presented to me even if it was in Saudi
Arabia where I'd be put to death I would
suck that dick dry and I'll be stoned
for it - I don't care ready look I don't
know what's going on that's how much I
love them that I would suck their dick
even in Saudi Arabia where it's
punishable by death it's beautiful man
it's a nice thought isn't it I don't
know I'm not sure it's not I think it's
nice that I would be willing to die to
suck their dick out of pure love and
adoration all right guys we'll see you
on Wednesday
all right with Andrew Yi a gang enjoy
the weekend and we are completely brain
dead
sorry bye